>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD,
NEW DETAILS ABOUT FEDERAION IN
FLORIDA REPUBLICANAN TTTZ.
POLITICAL FA.F AN ONGOINGLICAN
ALSO EXAMININGTH
AATIONSHIP WITH
CNN'S PAULA REID JOINSS NO
PAULE INVESTORTE JE.URCES BRIEF
SAY THE JUSTICPAS
NIZING AINVOLVING CONGRESSMA
ETSEVERAUN SPECIFICALLY LOOKINGT
WHETHER THAT PAN ORCHESTRATED EF
ILLEY INFLUENCE THE CONGRESSMANA
EVZ
IS UNDER INVESTIGATION FOR ALLE
RELATIONSHIP WITA
WITHER PNEHAE PARTIES  GAETZARTR
INVOLVED WOMEND SEX IN
EXCHANGE FOR MONEY.W CNN RNEDHA
INVESTATNEKE
EX  THAT IS JOEL GREHE'SORMER SE
AND HE'S EXPECTED LEAD  X AF
GUILTY IN THE CONG
REPORT AT AUM
INDUSTRYLILKING ABOU>> THE CON
HIY  FOR
PIGISLATION ATAND INTRODUCED
THE LE
E LE TING THE DACCORDING TO REP
Z ON T
AS ONE OF HIBE, AN
HAVREPEATEDLY
INTERSECTED OVER MIC
MAAR BACK AS 201 THETENTE IN
FLORIDA, INTRODUD
MARIJUANLEIOWITHLAN TH
ONE WEEK AFTER
PASSED H MIC RIJUANA CONSULTINGT
FULLY WRITTEN DRT OF THE BILL
THAT THE DOCTOR'S GROUP HA
SHING AND HER GAETZ FOR PIRAZOLC
THE SUBSTANCE  REPORTING
CONGRANIOUSLYENIED G
X.
>> THANKUBPPLE WITH HOW E THE GU
HONANCPESIO
IS FACING UNIQ CHALLENGES ANGLIR
OCRAT.
LET'S BRING IN WASHINGTOAU CHIE
ELI CAMADAM EAKER.GRATULATIONS .
SPEAKER PELOSI'S
H THE SO CALLED
SQUAD, THESE FOUR YOUNG VERY
OG
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS WOMEN,LATIOA
RESSMAN, EIAY WITH
EZN DAY OND CALLED ON
IN A SIT-IN.
LO IOC
HER PASSION.
SH I'VE BEEN YWAPUST FORWARD TH
>> WELL,S STIL
IT IS PUBLICLY RESPECTFU
IT'S SOMETIMRA
SEE MORE AS NG
THE SQUAD  MOST
PROGE FORCES IN E MOCRATIC PARND
DETE.RATIC HOUSE PUS POLICIEYOU
SHE H
CIEST E'
A  WHAU ACTUALLYETE,THINK THAT'M
METHEYS  TQULAE POINTS
NOTL OF THE
US AND WHA
I KNOW THAT A LOT OMESS.
INK THAT THE DUN LANGUAG T
WIN SEATS.
T, THEY LOSTEA
>> A BIGPRISE IN THE L
ELECTION.
NANCY PELOSI UP UNTIL TH
HOUSE.TURNS CAME IN THOUGHT THE
UND THE POLICERHETORASE IN P WH'
ANOTHER ONE PACT COURT.
YOU ARE JERRY D LENG THE
CHAIARY
COMMIT IDU
TO A HOUSE VOTE? PELSUPREME COUI
PRESIDENT HARRIS WILL MAKE HIY T
BIDEN WHENT ONGRESS.
WE ALLEN
TORE UN SPEECH
SITUIOALD TR SIMILAR
DI GET A SENSETE THAT
>> YOUW, TALKE
LENGTH ABOUT THAT, ANDHE -
WAANTO  WAG TH -P HAD HEA E AS .
SEE WHAT.
THERE  S HAD
SHCOA PE
SHE W THAT'S
UP TN OF THE DAIS, THE MADE
LITTLE TEAR IN THER SO SHE
CO HERLA W H ERD KEPT M
IN THE MARGIN AND BY THE THEWASA
SHRED TD
VICE PRESIDENT MIKNCO SHE WAS D
SYMBIZESNOT THAT
HER FANS CONSIDEIC WHE
SHE LEFT
2018.S,O YOU THAT SHE
HE COA
F
OPTICS.
HOW IMPORTANT T SKILL ASOU K
WASHINGTON FOR SNG?
>> YEAH.
RE
TH IS IN THE
THE TRUMP ADMINI
DRAC FACE
OF THE OPPIT STARTING WITH
WAE RED COAT, AFTER  OF THE D C
SCHUMER WERE SITTING DOWWITH
ENT AND VICEIDENT, ANDHA RETOR
SWASN'T IN SUCH A
POSI W HERS
WHAT WAS GOING T FOR THEOF Y>>
THE LESSONOF FROM NANCY
PELOSI SAYING INT, QUOTEVE THE .
DISPLAY A GUCCI GLOVE WHEN
POSSIBLE ANDIEN IRON FT EEE WHE
PELO'S IN PAICL, YOU KNOW,
RAYBURN.REPRESENTATIVES SINCE SA
SHLEPERSONALLY FHE
LE HAD IN IS L T IN 2008 AND
WANT TOTH
D GUCCI GLOVE S
LOOKED AT THAT, ANLOCURRENT DEB.
SHE'S GOTTEN THROUGH THEISRIN C
THE ND
BILL THROUGH THE HOUSE.AT PNEN
AGAINST NANCY
>>Y TRUE.
ATR
PO